عندي الاخبار المهمه العلميه السعوديه في
الفضاء اي اكس 2 والتي يقوم بها رائد
الفضاء السعوديه ينعال القرني وريان
البرناوي برفقه اخرين ومهمتها اجراء اربع
عشره تجربه علميه وبحثيه في شتى المجالات
فامسم اجراء اتصال لاسلكي بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه من محطه ارضيه بالرياض تحدث داخل
لها مجموعه من الطلاب مع رائدى الفضاء علي
وريان متابع
[موسيقى]
هوتيل
والله متحمس جدا متحمس ومتوتر شويه
جهاز بمنطقه معينه لازم منطقه معينه عشان
يسمعونا فوق المملكه وبعدين لما يصلون
بالدائره اللي
قريبه من المملكه يشبك مع بعض
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
عظيمه جدا
شكله جاذبيه
اللي موجود 89 انا مره فخوره اني كلمت
رائده فضاء سعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ويبدو ان هذه المهمه السعوديه اصبحت مصدر
الهام وفتحت الافاق ووساعات الطموحات لدى
للشباب حيث
ظهر الطفل السعودي مشعل والذي يسمي نفسه
رائد فضاء المستقبل في فيديو تحدث فيه عن
حلمه بان يصبح رائد فضاء واكد انه سيكون
قادرا على تحقيق الحلم في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
ستصبح هناك
تجربه النوم هيا بنا
[موسيقى]
وقت النوم
السلام ليس في
او نحن
في كوكب
اذهب
[موسيقى]